so when you mentioned CCTV footage of
what right so CCTV footage of so CCTV
for each of the imperative it basically
shows what it'll give us a very good
window into understanding where these
women detained were they controlled were
they let out it won't give us the full
scope but it'll give us a significant
score both inside and outside to have
the CCTV they also had CCTV in the house
where the girls were living none of that
has been included so they didn't they
didn't include the CCTV footage that was
actually in the house when the girls
were living there that's right and so
and the defense wants to include it and
that's going to be I'm going to explain
why that violets and other articles
within international law which is then
incorporated into romanula